joining us on the line is my friend and
famous fox news host greg gutfeld his
book is
the plus self-help for people who hate
self-help which makes perfect sense
because when i thought people who are
going to write a self-help book i got to
i got to tell you
greg got felt i that was not going to be
like my top 10 list of self-help i was
like jordan peterson
like dr phil and greg gutfeld that was
definitely a new what
what drove you greg gutfeld to write a
self-help book
i think i was tired of hearing myself
talk about the problems
and i've been writing books since and
doing these monologues and talking about
what's wrong
and i i think i just got sick of hearing
myself and i thought well what if i
could actually
figure out solutions to these problems
and a lot of them had to do with
mob culture social media cancel uh
canceled culture
but also and i don't know if you
remember this ben when we talked but i
worked in service journalism i worked at
uh men's health
and prevention magazine i did like this
self-help how-to stuff every month
the only difference was i had absolutely
no wisdom
i was in my 20s and 30s i was half the
time i was drinking
the other half god knows what i was
doing but i wasn't be
i was the last person you would ever
take advice from
and that's the way all a lot of
self-help people are is that you find
out when you
when you hire them for a show or you do
something with them and you see them
behind the scenes
they're absolutely awful they're a mess
they can't get their life together the
pit the people that pitch
to me uh self-help stuff like how to be
more
organized or how to get the perfect job
and you meet them and they're
scary so i realized it's true
but then so now i'm like in my 50s and
i'm sitting here and i'm writing about
these things
and i feel like i was a broken record
and i didn't even have a book contract
i thought that all of these
psychological problems
can be improved because to me they're
psychological so why not
try so i decided to just be
a corny cheesy self-help writer
so how do you stay happy how do you stay
happy in the news cycle i mean honestly
this is something i battle with every
day i got a lot of questions about this
it's very difficult to be happy when
you're in the news cycle constantly i
can see how people who just disconnect
from the news disconnect from social
media yeah
can can live a happy life but it's a
very difficult thing to be as you are or
as i am
in the news every day and the news only
covers bad stuff happening
in the world and then asks you to
comment on it so how do you stay happy
in that climate
well i think the thing is is i know it's
it's the awareness of that the fact that
you are stuck in some weird nightmarish
cycle
that only makes money only makes money
with discontent as as long as a is
against
b uh uh everything's fine but the moment
that like a and b come together like
blacks and whites or or
uh poor and middle class then then the
news cycle just collapses and it doesn't
work
so knowing that helps you step out of it
i have this conversation with my wife
all the time because i
like i go you don't understand and she
goes yeah because i i'm
i don't i'm out of that loop
she goes she goes hiking she goes skiing
she does
she does her stuff but i can't even when
i'm away
i can't kind of get out of it because
it's always going to be there it's like
when people tell you to turn off twitter
or social media
it's not like you can turn off the rain
cloud they're still going to come after
you ben like if you say hey i don't
follow that stuff they're still going to
try to get you fired it's not like
they're going away so it's something
that
you only have to put in perspective and
it is true i mean scott adams says go
outside go for a walk and you realize
the world hasn't changed
and he's kind of right the moment you go
outside is probably the best
remedy for the news because you see how
little it outside changes unless you're
in midtown manhattan
or downtown los angeles as you watch it
decline into this bizarre dystopian
nightmare
so one of the big kind of disconnects i
think is is
it's true that it's it's harder for
people who are in the news to to feel
happy
but it's also true that if you're in a
position that you are or i am you can
sort of refuse to be canceled what do
you recommend to folks
who you mentioned cancel culture what do
you reckon i get this question a lot
you got a bunch of people who are
working at just normal companies and
they feel completely silenced there's a
poll that came out last week saying 62
of americans said they're afraid of
saying what they think about politics
because they're afraid they're going to
be canceled or they'll be blow back or
they'll be fired
what do you recommend to them in terms
of leading a happy life because
obviously you know you can't avoid
politics completely
and in doing that kind of hiding your
own politics is actually a pretty
stressful thing so what do you recommend
to folks who don't have the ability to
just say no to the cancer culture the
way that you greg gutfeld do
or thank god i do yeah i think the um
the sad reality is if you're not wealthy
or if you're not protected
or if you don't own your own business
like you're in a better position ben
because you own your stuff i mean i work
for a company
so i'm you know i'm vulnerable the
moment that you know i become a
liability
i'm gone the shoot comes up but you i
mean it's like
i mean you and you think about you know
obviously joe rogan
and dave rubin the smart way for
forward is doing what you guys are doing
and i've always known that and i've
always had my foot in that
but i never jumped i instead have always
been kind of like i like where i work
but i realize
that as long as i'm not autonomous i'm
always going to be vulnerable
but i do think okay for the average
person
they have no choice at this point but
they have to lay low
they can't like you gotta like you you
have to understand that cancel culture
is a first amendment workaround
you can say like you could say hey you
have the freedom of speech
yes but but you you could still ruin my
career
ruin my you know destroy my livelihood
and drive me to suicide
if you so wish but i still have the
freedom of speech
but this it's people have to understand
that cancer culture is
the first it's historical it's the first
first amendment workaround and i think
that for now
until we decide as a culture to share
the risk
which is a phrase i first heard from uh
claire lehman
when i interviewed her and it resonated
with me that until we share the risk and
that means
your bosses share the risk and i thought
at fox they do
but not everybody does i mean you can
get fired like that
i mean you read about people that will
you know they'll tweet all lives matter
or blue lives matter and then they have
to resign
or the guy that had to resign because he
wrote a piece
against women in the military 35 years
ago
but he had to resign now i think i think
that we have to
start sharing the risk we can be the we
could be the better
the better angels meaning you know we
could be defining people at their best
and not their worst we can always
forgive like i've forgiven people
who will not forgive me i would name
them but i'm not but like i forgave some
dude not forgave
he was about to lose his job as a left
winger and i defended him
a month later he comes after me it's
like
it's like i thought maybe there would be
some kind of mutually assured
forgiveness
no not at all so then that makes me
think well maybe
i should listen to like some of the guys
at breitbart who say like no mutually
assured forgiveness mutually assured
destruction if they come after you you
come back to them and i can see that
point too
but i think you know right now we as the
people have to be more open about
sharing the risk
and defend people who might not defend
you
uh that's the altruistic way i'm not
sure it's gonna work but i'm hopeful
that this can't keep going on because i
think the left are gonna run out of
people to destroy
i think yeah i mean that's my hope too
is that the radical
left is actually becoming so radical and
they're closing the overturned windows
so much
that you're starting to see mainstream
liberals go this is this is too much we
can't handle this now that's still a far
cry from mainstream liberals deciding
they'll actually have a conversation
with greg gottfeld or with
me obviously they won't open the overton
window enough they'll it'll be just open
enough for them to escape but not open
enough for them to actually have a
conversation with someone who disagrees
so
they're gonna have to get over that
barrier the book is the plus self-help
for people who hate self-help
by greg gutfeld so greg in the book one
of the things that you talk about
is the idea that you you really need to
move forward
all the time that forward momentum is a
big thing that if you wake up in the
same place you were three years ago
you're doing something wrong so how do
people
gain a sort of life momentum especially
right now when it feels like there's so
much stagnation it's so difficult
to get up and push forward in a in a
chaotic climate where you're being told
very often you can't even go to work you
can't interact with other people
what how do you create a trajectory for
yourself
well there's the site there's a
psychological uh component and then just
the plain practical
physical one the psychological one is uh
for me
was learning to reject the sunk cost
meaning that all the
the investment that i had in something
before and i
i remember this feeling uh when i was
younger
and in relationships like and you see
this in relationships
mainly uh people that have been together
for three years
but it's terrible they're not married
but it's terrible but they're together
for three years because there's so much
investment that they put in and they
think like
if i walk away from this now uh
all of that is gone people are like that
with ideas
and they're like that with jobs and
they're like that with relationships
they're like that with cities like i've
lived here
all my life so i think the first thing
for me was the sunk cost
what can i what can i change
uh that i know i've been doing a lot of
but what can i
like can i walk away from this i won't
get into the things that i've walked
away with but a lot of them were
connected to some costs
the other thing for me is um kind of
like
i i have a whole chapter on this on
creating your own curriculum
which is basically just uh finding out
stuff to do that you've always wanted to
do
now that you have this infinity of
of of expertise in the internet like if
i i say this in my book like if you just
type in three things
introduction to philosophy introduction
to
uh garage rock uh introduction to
martial arts and you've just plugged it
into youtube
you could get yourself started on three
different kinds of things
you might run out of expertise at a
certain point where you actually need to
find somebody that can teach you
but it will get you to a certain place
where you're confident to do that
so i thought i think that like right now
we're at this rare opportunity to
re-invent education
and and especially in coping i've been
doing things that i mean i
like the guitar is a good example
because i just thought if i'm gonna be
alone i'm gonna
i'm gonna re-learn how to play guitar
and i did it using youtube and that was
one of the
one of the classes that i took and i've
been reading you know i've read
uh a lot of philosophy uh rene gerard
uh a lot of the stoics because the
stoics are in everybody got into stoics
during covet did you notice this
i did too but i found that the stoics
are really repetitive
but that's a reason for that because
they're you know they've got one road
yeah it's stoic yes
so that's the the psychological and the
in
the uh uh and the kind of the physical
thing
is constantly learning uh scott adams
uses the phrase talent stack
which you know always always try like
don't just
have one thing you can do really well go
out learn how to do things like public
speaking is always going to help you
things like that so it's
always kind of like building up your
talents all right so
let's talk a little bit of news because
obviously that is the other business
you're in when you're not giving
self-help advice to people in the great
book the plus self-help for people who
hate self-help
so president trump obviously riding
pretty well behind in the polls
at this point uh i'm not a believer in
the idea that the polls are completely
wrong i think that even if the polls are
off
the president doesn't look good at this
point but there's a lot of time until
the election
what do you think that trump needs to do
to turn this around because the media
factors are never going to change they
hate him they're going to lie about him
they're going to take everything he says
the worst possible
at the at the worst possible tenure so
what does trump need to do to turn this
thing around
i part of this i believe is out of his
control
i think the covid the kovit thing is
such a curveball
that it can go one way or the other um i
think
uh pushing the continual uh the kind of
the best
news and doing these uh rather
straightforward
pressers have been helpful as opposed to
the kind of antagonistic ones that are
entertaining
uh and exciting but kind of destructive
i i the last couple ones he's done
i thought were pretty pretty on the
money um pretty basic
and and i mean not talking about the
reductions in mortality is really
important
but we don't you know the thing is and
he's got i think he really has to be
pro-business which he is but you know
talk about
you know every time you it's like i came
up with this theory called game over
theory
which is the media and the left look at
every story
like an old video game that has a very
short story development and ends
immediately and you have to start
over again every day you have to start
over the story because you're not saving
your progress
so every time you talk about kobit you
have to start over and go
of course we want everybody to practice
social distancing and wear their masks
and we don't want people to die you have
to do you have to start over the
conversation every day in order to make
the progress
and talk about getting back to work and
opening up businesses
so i think he has to be on the side of
the business on the side of businesses
on the side of workers always
reiterating that we want you to be safe
but that this we cannot shut down the
world's greatest economy i think he's
got to be hitting that
um i think touting as much progress as
you can on
the uh the pro prophylaxis and the in
the
in the vaccine whether it happens or not
i'm i'm skeptical in the vaccines just
because we
we haven't had that much great effort i
mean do we we don't even have an aids
vaccine that we've been trying forever
but
i'm gonna be positive say hopefully it's
true positive on that
um i think on law and order i think he
needs to be
uh i think stronger with our police
because i think that's going to become a
bigger story and be on the side of
communities
that are under siege and also i think
the outreach
uh with the black community is always
important especially with what's going
on
in chicago and the in the rising crime i
mean he's got to be on that side because
the democrats are deserting them so i
think that would be good too but i'm
going to say that like
and to your point when you say it like
uh the polls can't all be wrong
but i'm assuming they might be half
wrong just because i don't know a single
person
that is telling the truth about what
they're going to do
back in 2016 people were reticent about
what they were going to say
it's only gotten worse if you're going
to wear a red hat anywhere
there's a 50 chance you're going to get
smacked in the head uh
there's going to be people who if they
know where you live they're gonna come
and get you
in the sense of doxing you or showing up
and protesting if you have any political
beliefs that are counter to the
conformity
so um it's even i think it's more
intense that you hide your
that you hide your true beliefs and also
i don't know how
i mean the one advantage biden has and i
think it's real
and i think you probably feel this way
the hatred for trump
is probably the strongest of any
political
leader pro since reagan for the left i
mean
uh when i mean i was uh you were just
two years old where was i in the
re-election i think the re-election
84 so i was 20 and i was at berkeley
and i mean reagan was hitler i mean it
was
bad bad and then uh it was amazing how
shocked
everybody was at cal when he won and
you it was it was because nobody said
anything nobody was
to say anything especially in berkeley
and i feel like today
everywhere is berkeley yeah in the sense
that the academy
the academic stifling of thought has
left um you know uh brett weinstein's
what was the name of the call evergreen
college evergreen state college i mean
he warned about this
that this stuff was going to end up
leaving and come out
everywhere and it has and i feel like
we're living in an environment
where we're all like we're all like at
sproul hall in
berkeley yeah we all got to like we all
got a nod
to the protesters give the thumbs up hey
we're with you
because because then they won't come for
you yeah that's what we are
well you know this does go back to some
of the themes that you talk about in the
plus self-help for people who hate
self-help
and that is how do you sort of get out i
think location is going to become a
bigger and bigger issue in america i
think that
if you're a conservative in a blue area
this is a miserable time for you and i
think it's going to get a lot more
miserable before it gets less miserable
i think we are going to see a mass
migration of people from blue areas to
red areas
as the city starts to deteriorate now
you're you've been spending most of your
time
in big blue cities how do you stay how
do you keep a sense of sanity in a city
where
if you wore a maga hat you'd actually
experience the possibility of getting
your
your head broken you know what uh
it's weird because like so i live in
i've lived in uh
manhattan for a long time but i also
live upstate i i got a cabin
where i am right now which is oddly
people don't get this but like when you
when you're going to certain rural or
country areas it's very liberal
it's like that's because you know what
it's the home of the second homes
and so you see the same signs i am um
i have to defend new york in one way for
one we have the worst mayor in history
the worst mayor in history the amount of
taxes we pay we get nothing back i
cannot wait to leave
i cannot wait to get the hell out but
unfortunately
i'm never gonna get out i i work at fox
right unless we create some other kind
of fox satellite
i'm stuck here and my wife who's grown
up in cities all her life
from moscow to london to new york she
ain't going anywhere like
like she will not leave she we you know
she loves our neighborhood so
that's my insult it's interesting in new
york
how little you run into politics if you
don't if you want to avoid it
right now i'm not well known enough like
tucker to get accosted
but i will you know i go to restaurants
in my neighborhood i live downtown
um i get stared at but nobody bothers me
maybe because i think i'm a little
unbalanced which i think is helpful
to me to look a little to look a little
crazy and i do look a little crazy
but also it is amazing how many people
in new york are in the closet completely
in the closet
fox heads shapiro heads republicans
and you find it out whenever you're uh
at a restaurant and you meet
the people who run the restaurant the
people who know
who have to deal with uh uh councils and
and politicians and fines they are the
business the businessman in new york
they aren't bleeding our heart libs and
they hate de blasio
they have to virtue signal you know but
they do but they
they do it as they do it as little spot
a little as possible but after what
happened in my neighborhood i live in
soho
i was destroyed in june by the looting
i think there were a lot of less
liberals that morning
than there were the night before and um
i saw it coming and i i i when i was
watching minneapolis i said this is
coming and i know it's coming and it was
one of the worst it was probably one of
the worst things i've i've been through
and i wasn't even in my apartment my
wife was and uh she was
trapped in there it was insane but
anyway i digress
uh i i can't leave
so you gotta like you just gotta do what
you do um
there is a thing where i told my wife
that if if we stay
i run for mayor but i was lying i was
hope i was trying to scare her
into leaving but she said oh you're
gonna run for mayor
oh that'll be interesting go for it and
she called my bluff
but it would be nice to have somebody
run for mayor who is not
a communist and i know if i ran i would
lose but i would do okay but i would
lose
you know what i mean i did it right
william around for mayor he ran
to lose and it was not bad for him so i
really would love to see
greg gutfeld running for mayor just the
debates between you and that giant weird
groundhog murderer
would be delightful the groundhog
murderer you will never live that down
uh the worst
and by the way all he does right now is
symbolic gestures
talking about um signs and and and
placards and and and trump this is trump
that
as shootings and murders skyrocketing
and i can't believe i mean how do the
democrats deal with this
like how can you turn a blind eye to
this the only explanation i have for
that
is if the democrats raise their concerns
about violence and crime
that somehow their brain that aligns
them with trump
in alignment with trump to them is far
worse than death
on their street which is a tragic and
sad cowardly perspective
it's pretty insane it's pretty insane so
final question for you here greg
obviously we're talking about sort of
the racial situation and the riots that
we're seeing across the country do you
think this lets up after november
because it it feels like
you know there should be fair unanimity
when it comes to covet there should be
fair unanimity when it comes to
hey america can always do better with
police brutality but overall this is not
a racist country most your neighbors
aren't racist and also
probably we shouldn't be allowing
rioting and looting and yet there is no
unity
it seems almost like americans are being
blackmailed into
supporting democrats simply so that this
will stop and it seems like many in the
media are pushing this well if trump
goes away
then all this will stop do you foresee
that if biden wins in november suddenly
covered will be off the front pages and
so will race riots
i would not i'm so cynical that i agree
with that in fact i
tweeted the there was a headline i think
it might have been from the atlantic
said it was a guy saying like hey you
know all these riots
you know this this is this is it's going
to get worse if trump wins
so they're basically extorting the
american public
and this is building towards that it's
like you know if we don't get that
get the orange monster out and put in
you know sleepy joe
the whole world's gonna crumble and i
disagree with their with their acclaim
because joe will joe will roll over to
the left i always say this
the left can't take yes for an answer so
even if they get somebody in there
it's not enough they're gonna want the
old white man out too by the way i wanna
uh there's a point i'm gonna make on the
five today
i'm watching this complete cultural
appropriation of black lives matter by
angry shrill white leftists and
uh i i assume they're with antifa but
they might not be but they're all
dressed in black
and they're all almost always white and
i can see
blm actually kind of getting tired of
this
because this is the equivalent of
vanilla ice
after grand master flash it's like
they're coming in
and co-opting something that it is
organic and authentic whether you agree
or not with everything that they talk
about
it is organic and it's authentic what
you're seeing with these anarchists
and these white screeching leftists is
the opposite of authentic
it's uh it's an attention-seeking
uh and it's it's like
it's a desire for attention and it's i
if i were in black lives matter i would
be like
get out of here leave me alone you're
making this
worse because they are well i don't know
greg got felt the book is the plus
self-help for people who hate
self-help go pick it up it's on sale
today right i mean it comes out or
a couple days from yeah it's out today
out today so go check it out right now
put greg at the top of the best seller
list help him
defeat trump hurt my dog by mary trump
on the best seller list this week
by the way fan you're on my show don't
forget you're on my show this weekend
perfect i think right yeah i think
that's right so
looking forward to that and then you'll
return the favor we'll tell each other
all right yeah you look like you're
surprised by that information uh dude i
have no idea what's going on in my own
life i just don't
i have three kids under seven and i'm
not sleeping well that's great
the book is the plus self-help for
people who hate self-help go check it
out now greg really appreciate the time
talk to you soon
you got it buddy thanks man see you
later
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content